so i just want to quote my father dick
johnson
and say how sweet it is to be here with
the many collaborators on this film
and this is a film we made together
with my father and one of our
operating principles was that
we would try to look for the unseen
things and the unseen perspectives and
so
this sort of chance for all of us to
talk together about what it took to make
this
movie um is really meaningful especially
in this moment of the pandemic that sort
of lets us all to be together even when
we can't be together
now the question is do you know which
room you live in oh yeah i do
where do you live right in this room
here nicely done
do you mind if i sit down no are you
tired would you like this a little
no leave it in leave it in leave it in
thank you
i'm gonna sit down uh how sweet it is
yes indeed you tired am i tired my feet
are like uh concrete blocks
[Music]
but you know my father was drifting away
uh the dementia was taking him away from
me
and um i'm gonna toss it to you pete
horner
uh yeah well certainly it was uh it was
a real collaboration with all of us and
with
your dad and uh i think we all kind of
felt that
connection and wanted the audience to
feel that connection with him
uh he he's sort of the core and drives
it all um
and yeah i mean i think that's one thing
we talked about early on we had a very
early collaboration and we
talked about uh and explored with sound
the idea of drift and connection to
reality and um so a lot of the scenes
play
you know as verite and uh we you know we
put in a lot of foley so you would feel
close
to you know the the tangible experience
of it but then
other sections we we've really looked
for places where we could get into his
subjective experience um you know of
sort of drifting away and
you know and so we use the sound to do
that
yeah and you know you see him here
basically saying like
go ahead you can kill me if you want but
just pass it by me before you do it
right so there's
all these states represented and maureen
i know that you and i have talked a lot
about the like
the range of cinema language we were
trying to employ
to connect to this uh changeling
uh dementia and what it was doing to my
dad
yeah and i think this clip really shows
the kind of two poles that we were
working under which is cinema magic
and then also cinema verite and so for
instance we have
we start with the floating chair which
is a green screen
element with some special effects we
have stunts
we have special effects makeup we have a
car crash
high speed filming which allows for the
slow motion feel of it
and the elongation of time and then we
end with that wonderful dance and music
interlude and i feel like in just this
eight and a half minutes
we really get a sense of the whole range
of what we were going for
in this film i mean the line
nails that we always went back to was
this idea of
this film will teach us how to make it
and
you know maureen like we didn't know we
were going to use all of those
methodologies but that was what ended up
happening
um and you know i think
marilyn you and katie chevini on the
production team
constantly were pulling us back into
why why use this cinema language what is
this about now what for
um so you know just to take us back to
the euthanasia
moment um tell us about the why
that you are always pushing us towards
well i think this
you know in the specificity there was a
universal storytelling and so for me
you know you would have these really
poignant moments with your dad which
were probably
normal conversation for you guys
throughout your life but where we get to
glimpse
and it and it can be a kind of
instruction manual for people
how do you have these difficult
conversations and i think when the film
was able to both rise above itself
it was like entirely entertaining but
also rise above itself for this
universal truth
i always felt really struck um that the
film would succeed
and i know in this scene also we had the
flip of that which is
you know first do no harm dj always has
to be
cared for in whatever state he was in
and i think
as certain things in the film evolved we
started to realize
are we are we skating too close to the
line and therefore why still do it or
or why pull it back and and show the
audience that restraint too
absolutely and like to stay committed to
that we weren't going to force him to do
anything he didn't want to do
and he wanted it to be a funny movie i
was struck when you said the word struck
by the connection to sound and the fact
of the thwack
the moment when the board hits my father
in the neck
uh pete horner can you talk about the
tone of that thwack
yeah i mean you know that's something
that we worked
on together a lot both in that scene and
and in other scenes where there's
the stunts and you know there's such a
range of what you can
uh achieve in terms of how much pain you
feel or how much
you know comedy you feel or you know
horror or whatever and it's all
contained in
you know which sound which frequencies
you know what
level um and it just took us
you know going through a bunch of sounds
together and deciding you know which is
the most
satisfying thwack for that moment but
you know it's really
i guess trying to connect us to his
experience but it's also
just acknowledging the the filmmaking
process i mean we let ourselves get a
little
cinematic a little you know hollywood in
places and then other places we would
just keep it
you know very very realistic
yeah i mean what i've learned from
working with you on camera person
was that i wanted sound mixing earlier
in the process because what happens with
sound is that you feel things
in your body in and you don't know
until you hear it what you will feel um
and so that part of our experimentation
was let's go in early and often
to a sound mix that we can do and redo
the way that
you know editing happens we re we do and
redo things
um but uh nelson i want to pass it to
you because
as you know from the beginning i really
wanted to get this story
of what had happened to my mom
with her mom's death into the film
because i sort of felt like it was the
heart of things
because it has to do with the sudden
death
the images that we see that we can never
unsee
um and how do we cope with
the loss um over time having
you know sort of lived through the most
traumatic thing possible
um so maybe talk to us a little bit
about
that in this movie and in this sequence
yeah yeah
i mean the film takes us through this
journey from the the very beginning you
have this idea this kind of crazy idea
let's film
you know you killing your dad your dad
dying over and over
and it's it's in this sequence that the
reason for that
becomes clear and i don't think it was
clear to us when we started making the
movie
why that was why that was the idea we
knew it was a good idea
but we didn't know why until we kind of
threw all these balls up in the air and
had all these these emotions and
and these themes and symbolisms going on
at the same time and then when we
discovered
at this point that it was it was to get
at
that sense of loss for you and your dad
and your mom
all at the same time through cinema that
these moments all come together in in
this one sequence so you have
you have death you have stunts you have
comedy you have sleep you have heaven
you have all these things happening
right here
in in this in this central bit it took
us a while to find but it's where
it's where the film really begins to pay
off
the slow motion heaven was fascinating
because you
really really wanted to do slow motion
high
speed i think we ended up shooting at
like at least 800 frames per second for
for that sequence and many others on the
stage
and um it's it's something that's i i
kind of think a lot
that it's used a lot in commercials but
your approach to using that was
actually to extend a moment to kind of
allow
us to have that moment in and just
really wallow in it and it was very much
uh like a lit motif for what you were
trying to do
in the making of this film with your
father was to try to keep those moments
longer than you knew they were going to
be possible and
it's funny that you know for me i always
think of it
the reason why i wanted to use slow
motion
um was that i wanted to enter
my father's present which seemed like it
was
you know his present was um so
intense because of the dementia sort of
like how could i
find a way to get into that space where
you
you ask one question and then ask the
same question right after the other but
i love what you're saying about
how it's about lingering and savoring
and holding on to something um
this sequence of the dance you know we
made it without music
to dance to because it was in slow
motion so
there's a there's a lot of ways in this
film that we reverse engineer things we
we do something and then we come back to
it and figure out how to do it so we
actually wrote music to the dance after
we had cut it
um the wonderful john kimbrough wrote
the music
but when we had finished it i still it
was still
not doing the things that i wanted it to
do and i came
to the sound mix pete with this just
real
wish that we go further um so
take it away yeah i mean i think the the
song works so well for
the the joy and um you know sort of
uh describing the energy of that moment
but i think you know you really wanted
to push it
to do more um you know and so
we kept trying to it did a good job of
moving us
you know through the scene in a really
you know fun and energetic way
but i think you were really trying to
get that feeling of the out of control
moment and the car crash and all that
and and that just wasn't present in it
and
and i remember we we kept trying to um
you know i embraced the sort of uh with
the blessing of the composer the
you know the remix idea and just
kind of went for it and broke it apart
and put it back together and
you know pit shifted some things here
and there um
but i remember there was it but i'm
always trying to do it in a very musical
way because that's
my instinct you know and i remember you
kept pushing me to say
i really want it to like break and i
want it to break like right here and you
point it to a you know a frame or
whatever and
it it felt very unmusical to break it
there and so it went against sort of my
core instincts
but i i just trusted you and i was like
okay let's just let's break it
and it was quote unquote wrong
but it also like revealed how we how we
break it and then put it back together
and um you know the only other thing
i'll say about it is that
it just felt like any time we could do
something that acknowledged a subtle
moment
in the image it it just drew meaning out
of it you know
um whether it's the the little bells or
the
um you know the uh the look on your
dad's face with the car crash like it
there's there's so many little details
that we could attach a sound to
the the clarinet playing just making
sure that that was featured when he was
on screen playing
all of that was so satisfying and i i
felt like
we found the meaning the deeper meaning
in it
i love what you're saying about like how
wrong that moment was you know dementia
is so
wrong death is so wrong yeah and part of
my wanting to to
break things in the unexpected moment
was to
replicate for the audience this effect
that dementia
creates is sort of whiplash of having
wrong things happen at the wrong moment
and and
and the person you love most and know
most suddenly saying something to you
that makes no
sense and completely blindsiding you um
so it's interesting how often i hear
myself saying
i i want to break things um you know
like that this film that i was trying to
kill my dad and break things and like
in some ways you know this just like
sort of defiance of dementia and
defiance of death
um was what we we struggled with in the
edit room
the whole time right now it's like we
were we and when you look at this
sequence it's completely
out of chronological order um and
none of these scenes um
needed to be there until they did
yeah i mean even that interview that
beautiful interview with your dad that
was relatively late
in in the process and he's very clear in
that moment and this is the thing
with with real dementia is you do have
moments of clarity and moments of
opacity and i think you know the film
sort of adopts
exactly that that approach it's that
that it can jump at any minute from
beautiful to to broken to funny to
tragic um yeah yeah
that scene is always so amazing to me
because he looks so youthful
to me there he looks so young and alive
in that shot
um and it was deep deeper into his
dementia than a lot of the film
so i think you're exactly right that the
film in its structure
um echoes dementia but i would also add
for all the things that are broken
you know that were broken in this one of
the things your dad did that is my
favorite shot of the whole film is
when we were filming the heavens scene
and they were dancing
and he kind of took his mask off even
though he wasn't necessarily supposed to
take his masks off
so he could get this full glimpse of his
young bride in a way he hadn't seen her
and yet must have been familiar right um
i just
i love that it's in the cut i love that
he did it
even though we were in the middle of
shooting a dance number like it's just
the i feel like for all we asked of your
dad these were the gifts
of of the film so this sort of one thing
leading to another
is what this film is all about i would
say
but trying to embrace not just breaking
things
not just crying about things but also
being playful
trying to figure out how does comedy
work trying to figure out how to laugh
in the face of the most painful things
all of that was part of the craft that
you know every person on this team
brought to the process